johnmiller is New York City's Deputy
Police Commissioner of intelligence and
counterterrorism he's also our former
senior correspondent John good morning
you just heard Elizabeth Palmer describe
it as a tense situation there that
controlled explosion as well as Sri
Lankan police finding 87 bombed
detonators at a bus station this morning
what are you hearing from your
intelligence counterparts well from the
time that started in about for something
in the morning yesterday Chief Tom
Galati chief of intelligence chief James
waters from counterterrorism the wheels
started turning in New York about
getting information about what they were
seeing there and what we heard we didn't
like which is a complex multi-location
attack that was very well-organized and
then making sure we put the pieces into
place here against any similar targets
you don't like the idea of a complex
multi destination because it suggests an
outside force outside of the country I
think when you look at this and you see
seven or eight locations off the bat in
your simultaneous staggers within other
later ones then raids on places where
suspects set off bombs what you're
looking at is the kind of operation that
would take a great deal of organization
a good deal of funding and more
importantly a fairly large number of
people for your average terrorist plot
which increases operational security how
do they run this for so long with so
much planning and so many wheels turning
and without without being on without it
being found exactly yeah but then
there's word that the government had
been told something ten days ago that
there could be an attack on a church
does that mean they didn't believe it
didn't take it seriously well they did
put out a notice to other government
officials warning that they were taking
this seriously and that the threat
itself touched a number of important
other investigations so and we've seen
this here in the United States Gail
that's one of those things that and I
think the government had the right take
on it let's figure out who did it and
get them first and then let's look at
our own processes after and that's what
they've said they're going to do as you
can see this morning they're worried
about more attacks coming and so the Sri
Lankan government shut down all social
media Facebook whatsapp some other
social media sites that are used therein
Lanka does that help the situation do
you believe that they took you know it's
hard to second-guess them from here you
know that it's always something that
sends a chill up a democratic government
but their stated reason was to prevent
misinformation and we've seen a lot of
discussion since they did that about
I believe the headline in when one major
newspaper was you know the the tensions
are the heat and social media can being
the match John we've been talking about
lone wolves for the last period of time
when we talk about terrorism but this
sense of coordination does that put in
mind for you any particular organization
so I think we have to ask ourselves a
couple of questions well let's let's
make it three number one is that the
resurgence of al-qaeda which has been
expanding its network to pick up these
affiliates because it is certainly more
their style number two is this an Isis
influenced group when Isis has gone from
being a Caliphate gone from being an
infantry and now remains solely as a
terrorist group and number three is this
a local group that has grown in
sophistication and and complexity right
three churches and luxury hotels is that
say anything to you it certainly does it
certainly says this was a attack
directed against Christians specifically
with a tinge of economic targets they
want to strike at a given religion and I
think we've been waiting for that shoe
to drop since the attack on the mosque
in New Zealand in that both on the
fifteenth for Isis and on the eighteenth
for al-qaeda their leaders have called
on all the affiliate groups to do an
attack in revenge for that
and I'm that is speculation there but
it's certainly something we have to look
at all right John Miller thanks so much
for being here John